Tyler Edmonds Bobby Johnson
Devante Sanford Marty Tankleff
Jeffrey disco Vic Anthony Caravela and
Travis Hayes you probably don't
recognize their faces together they
served 89 years for murders that they
didn't commit murders that they falsely
confessed to committee when they were
teenagers
I'm a forensic developmental
psychologist and I study these types of
cases as a researcher a professor and a
new parent my goal is to conduct
scientific research that helps us
understand how kids function in the
legal system that was designed for
adults in March of 2006 police
interrogated Brendan Dassey a 16 year
old high school student with an IQ
around 70 putting him in the range of
intellectual disability so here's just a
brief snippet of his for our
interrogation be honest I told you
before that's the only thing that's
gonna help you we already know what
happened okay we don't get honesty here
I'm your friend right now but I gotta
believe in you and if I don't believe in
you I can't go too bad for you okay
you're not tell us what happened your
mom said you'd be honest with us and
she's behind you every second there what
happens here that's what she said
she thinks you'd know more - we're in
your corner we already know what
happened they'll tell us exactly don't
lie
they told Brendan that honesty would set
him free but they were completely
convinced of his guilt at that point
so by honesty they meant a confession
and his confession would definitely not
end up setting him free they eventually
got a confession from Brendan that
didn't really make sense didn't match
much of the physical evidence of the
crime and his widely believed to be
false still it was enough to convict
Brendan sentenced him to life in prison
for murder and sexual assault in 2007
there was no physical evidence against
Brendan at all it was nothing more than
his own words that sent him to prison
for nearly a decade until a judge
overturned his conviction just a few
months ago the Dessie case is unique
because it made its way into a Netflix
series called making a murderer which
I'm sure many of you saw and if you
haven't you should definitely watch it
the Dessie case is also unique because
it led to such intense public outrage
people were very angry about how Brendan
was questioned and many assumed that his
interrogation had to have been illegal
it wasn't illegal as someone who's a
researcher in this area and is familiar
with police interrogation training
manuals I wasn't really surprised by
what I saw
the fact is dassey's interrogation
itself is actually not all that unique
and to be honest with you I've seen
worse so I understand the public outcry
about injustice and brendan dassey's
individual case but let's not forget
that approximately 1 million or so of
his peers are arrested every year in the
United States and may be subjected to
similar interrogation techniques
techniques that we know increase the
risk for false confession and I know
many people are going to struggle with
that term false confession and with
believing that false confessions
actually occur and I get that it's very
shocking and counterintuitive
why would someone confess and even give
gruesome details about a horrifying
crime like rape or murder if they hadn't
actually done it it makes no sense and
the fact is we can never know precisely
how often false confessions occur but
what we do know is that false
confessions or admissions were present
in approximately 25% of wrongful
convictions of people later exonerated
by DNA evidence turns out they were
innocent these cases are crystal clear
because we have the DNA so they didn't
do the crime and yet one quarter of them
confess to it anyway and at this point
from countless research studies we have
a pretty good sense of why people
falsely confess and why some people
like Brendan Dassey are at greater risk
for doing so so we know that youth are
especially vulnerable to providing false
confessions in one study of exonerations
for example only 8% of adults had
falsely confessed but 42% of juveniles
had done so of course if we're just
looking at you know wrongful convictions
and exonerations we're only getting part
of the story left out for instance are
the many cases that are resolved by
guilty pleas not trials from TV and news
headlines you may think that trials are
the norm in our legal system but the
reality is that 97% of legal cases in
the u.s. are resolved by pleas not
trials 97% also left out will be
confessions to more minor types of
crimes that don't typically involve DNA
evidence and aren't usually reviewed or
appealed following a conviction so for
this reason many refer to the false
confessions we actually do know about as
the tip of a much larger iceberg in our
research we found alarming rates of
false confession among teenagers we
interviewed almost 200 incarcerated 14
to 17 year olds and 17 percent of them
reported that they'd made at least one
false confession to police
what's also shocking to most is that
interrogations in the u.s. police are
allowed to interrogate juveniles just
like adults so they can lie to them it's
blatant lies like we have your
fingerprints we have your DNA your
friend is down the hall saying that you
know this was all your idea
lying to suspects is banned in the UK
for example but legal here in the US
even with intellectually impaired teens
like Brendan Dassey in our research most
of the incarcerated teens that we
interviewed reported experiencing high
pressure police interrogations without
lawyers or parents present more than 80
percent described having them threatened
by the police including with the
possibility of being raped or killed in
jail or being tried as in a goal
these maximization strategies are
designed to make suspects feel like deny
are pointless and confession is the only
option so you may have heard of playing
the role of good cop bad cop right well
this is bad cop juveniles are more
suggestible and susceptible to social
influence like the intense pressure
accusations and suggestions coming from
authority figures in interrogations more
than 70% of the teens in our study said
that the police had tried to befriend
them or indicate a desire to help them
out during the interrogation these are
referred to as minimization strategies
and they're designed to convey sympathy
and understanding to the suspect and
they imply that a confession will result
in more lenient treatment so in the
classic good cop/bad cop
oversimplification of police
interrogations this is good cop honesty
here Brenda is the thing that's going to
help you okay no matter what you did we
can work through that okay you can't
make any promises but we'll stand behind
you no matter what you did okay no
matter what you did we can work through
that hints of leniency like you just saw
with Brendon are especially powerful
among adolescents in part because they
evaluate reward and risk differently
than adults do confessing brings an
immediate reward to the suspect right
and now the stressful and pleasant
interrogation is over
so confessing may seem like the best
option to most teens who are less
focused on that long-term risk of
conviction and Punishment down the road
as a result of that confession I think
we can all agree that thoughtful
long-term planning is not a strength of
most teenagers that we know and by and
large the legal system seems to get that
young victims and witnesses should be
treated differently than adults but when
it comes to young suspects it's like the
kid gloves come off and treating
juveniles as though they're adults and
interrogations is a problem because
literally hundreds of psychological and
neuro scientific studies tell us that
juveniles do not think like adults they
do not behave like adults and they're
not built like adults adolescent brains
are different from adult brains even
anatomically so there are important
changes happening in the
structure and function of the brain
during adolescence especially in the
prefrontal cortex and the limbic system
and these are areas that are crucial for
things like self-control decision making
a motion processing and regulation and
sensitivity to reward and risk all of
which can affect how you function in a
stressful circumstance like a police
interrogation we need to educate law
enforcement attorneys judges and jurors
on juveniles developmental limitations
and how they can play out in a
high-stakes interrogation in one
National Survey of police officers
seventy-five percent of them actually
requested specialized training and how
to talk to children and adolescents most
of them had had none we also need to
consider having special protections in
place for juveniles in his ninety-one
page decision to overturn dassies
conviction earlier this year the judge
made a big deal about the fact that dasi
had no parent or other allied adult in
the interrogation room with him so
here's a clip of Brendon talking to his
mom after he confessed when it was
obviously far too late for him what do
you mean like this is stories like
different late I never did know at all
did you
huh not really what do you mean not
really my head so he sums it up pretty
beautifully there they got to my head we
don't know if the outcome would have
been different for Brendan if his mom
had been in an interrogation room with
him but it's certainly possible in our
research only 7% of incarcerated teens
most of whom had had numerous encounters
with police had ever had a parent or
attorney in the room with them when they
were questioned as a suspect few had
ever asked for a parent or attorney to
be present and you see this in lower
stakes situations - so we did a mock
interrogation experiment in our lab here
at FIU with parent permission for all
minors of course and all the appropriate
ethical approvals we falsely accused
teens and adults of cheating on a study
tasks an academic dishonesty offense
that we told them was as serious as
cheating in a class in reality
participants had witnessed a peer cheat
someone who was actually part of our
research team and was allegedly on
academic probation and we gave everyone
a tough choice you can lose your extra
credit for participating in the study or
accuse your peer who will probably be
expelled because of his academic
probation status of course in reality
none of these consequences would have
panned out and we fully debriefed all
participants afterward but most
teenagers 59% of them signed the
confession statement falsely taking
responsibility for the cheating only
three teams out of 74 are about 4
percent of them asked to talk to a
parent when we accused them of cheating
despite the fact that for most of them
their parent was literally sitting in
the next room during the study of course
cheating is far from murder and I know
that but it's interesting that so many
teens significantly more teens than
adults sign the confession saying that
they cheated they hadn't cheated but
they signed this form anyway saying that
they had rarely attempting to evolve a
parent in the situation other studies
tell the same story over 90% of
juveniles waived their Miranda rights
and submit to police questioning without
parents present in England and Wales
interrogations of juveniles must be
conducted in the presence of an
appropriate adult like a parent guardian
or social worker and this isn't
something youth have to ask for which is
great because research shows that they
won't it's automatic now having an
appropriate adult safeguard for
juveniles here in the US would not be a
cure-all for improving police
questioning of youth unfortunately
parents often lack the knowledge and
legal sophistication to appropriately
advise their children you can just look
at the case of the Central Park five
five teenagers who falsely confess to a
brutal gang rape in 1989 with their
parents by their sides and it took over
a decade to clear their names so the
appropriate adult really should be an
attorney or perhaps a trained child
advocate overturning dassey's conviction
the judge pointed out that there's no
federal law requiring that the police
even inform a juveniles parent that the
juveniles being questioned or honor that
juveniles request to have a parent in
the room so if you think about all of
this together for a second as a country
we've decided that juveniles cannot be
trusted with things like voting buying
cigarettes attending an r-rated movie or
driving but they can make the judgment
call to waive their Miranda rights
rights that we know from research most
teens don't understand or appreciate and
parents in the room depending on the
state that you live in your child can
waive these potentially waive these
rights without your knowledge and
without consulting any adult first now
no one and certainly not me wants to
prevent police from doing the very
important investigative work that they
do every day but we need to make sure
that they have appropriate training for
talking to youth as a parent and as a
researcher I think we can do better I
think we can take steps to prevent
another Brendan Dassey while still
getting the crucial information that we
need from children and teens to solve
crimes thank you